In the old days, there was a fig tree in the kingdom.
He was covered with thick black rags, his eyes were hateful, ...
... It was a terrible decoy that was flowing into a salty viscous saliva.
Some tried to fight the dragon ...
... The priests and magicians followed the curses in vain.
He was attacked by armed fighters with the best weapons, but the result was that they were burned.
The claws of the dragon and its jaws, its fire and its harsh silvery shield were so effective that they made it invincible.
The Dragon asked of mortal humans: ...
... Ten thousand men and women, randomly selected, ...
... in order to be delivered every evening to the foot of the mountain in order to eat them.
Because their weapons were useless, the king and the kingdom were not ...
... no choice but to pay the bloody sacrifice, ...
... and bear suffering, to fill the hunger of the dragon which can not be satisfied.
Even humans, with their infinite adaptability, have accepted the dragon tyrant as a reality of life;
... knowing, even accepting, that the last moments of each will be between his mouth.
How is the world to be otherwise?
The Kingdom began teaching its children that the dragon has its place ...
... in nature, and that the real meaning of being a human being is that you end up ...
... in the stomach of the dragon, where their short life motivates them to live a good life.
And that the dragon was helping the kingdom by blocking the population ...
... than growing too fast.
Through these teachings, attacks on the dragon stopped.
But the kingdom nevertheless continued to grow, slowly, and with it also the greatness of the dragon, ...
... where he became the size of the mountain on which he lived, and with his size increased his appetite.
Business logistics has become necessary to collect and transfer so many every day ...
... to the mountain is more concerned with the king than death and the dragon itself.
The king had to hire registrars to keep records of his choice.
There were collectors of people sent to bring the selected victims.
There were pension management staff paid to the torn families.
There were also Mawson traveling with the fateful fate ...
... on their way to the dragon, trying to ease their suffering.
There were scientists in the science of dragons, specialists in studying how to make these logistics tasks more effective.
Steam engines were invented and a railway station was established leading to the dragon's shelter.
The trains arrived at the mountain station crowded with people, and returned empty.
Some dragon scientists have also studied dragon behavior and collected samples ...
... from his falling scales, from his viscous saliva, and from his stray stubble with fragments of human bones.
The more they understand the beast, the more they become invincible.
But. . . Human sexuality is intriguing.
From time to time, one of them is given a good idea.
Others copy the idea, adding their own development.
Over time, many tools and systems are being developed.
Some of these tools make it easier to generate new ones.
Thus, the wheel of large invention, ...
... whose rotation was so slow that he did not realize in the older ages, ...
It began to accelerate, and humans, in the past, began to magically, ...
... running simultaneously across great distances, panning machines that can fly,
... and many other amazing things.
Some dragon scientists have argued that the time may have come for a new attack ...
... one of them invented a material so sharp and harsh that it could penetrate the dragon's scales.
It will not be easy, but if possible, a huge shell of this material will be made ...
And launched with sufficient force and accuracy, they may penetrate the dragon armor.
But it will be difficult, costly and time consuming.
Dragon scientists explained their proposal to anyone who was willing to listen.
But people were skeptical; they had learned that the dragon tyrant was invincible and that the sacrifices he was demanding were part of real life.
However, when they learned about the new material and the idea of ​​the shell, the curiosity of many of them was provoked.
When the king read about these plans, he decided to hold an open hearing ...
... The meeting was held on the last and most dark day of the year, in the Grand Hall of the Royal Castle.
People filled all the seats and crowded into the corridors.
The king's adviser first spoke: telling people that they must accept the inevitability of a dragon ...
... and that Dragon Management Department provides many job opportunities ...
... which will disappear when the dragon is killed, and anyway ...
... The treasuries of the kingdom were empty after the construction of the new railway.
After that the great dragon scientist explained how the proposed device would work, ...
... and how to manufacture the required amount of newly invented material.
If sufficient funding is available, the work can be completed within fifteen to twenty years.
With additional funding, possibly within twelve years. But in any case, there will be no guarantees.
The last speaker was the king's adviser on ethical matters:
"Let's say the project is technologically possible," said the counselor. "If that did not prove to me ...
You assume that you have the right not to be swallowed.
This is something that is full of arrogance and vanity. The palace of human life is a blessing.
Getting rid of the dragon, which may seem something appropriate to do, will undermine our dignity.
This preoccupation with killing the dragon will discourage us from fully realizing the ambitions ...
... that our life naturally refers to, rather than just living.
It is the nature of the dragon to eat, and our nature, my friends, can only be completed when we eat.
Dragon is necessary. Good dragon. "
Silence hung around the room.
Then one of the children shouted: "The dragon is bad!"
The father's parents blushed and pointed to him to shut up, but the child said again:
"The dragon is bad, it kills people ... I ate my grandmother ... I want to retrieve my grandmother."
The room was silent again. Then a woman stood up: "Kill my father's dragon."
A man followed and stopped in turn: "The dragon killed my wife and daughter."
The number of people standing still increasing. The room was dominated by the fact that the dragon killed everyone, the magnitude of the loss that resulted from this fact, and the weight of its presence.
The way to get rid of her button is far away but it may be possible.
The king looked at the child who had spoken first and declared: "Let us kill the dragon."
The next morning, a billion people who are aware that they, or those who love them, wake up may be sent to the dragon before the shell is fired.
While effective support for the Dragon End was limited in the past, ...
... it has now become a major priority and a primary concern in everyone's mind.
Gathering massive demonstrations for the missile project and urging the king to increase support, ...
... What the king actually did, he has enacted more financial appropriation laws and sold his summer castle, declaring:
"I believe that this Kingdom must commit itself to achieving a goal ...
... freeing the world from the old dragon's scourge before the end of the present decade. "
Thus a great technological race began against time.
The weapon industry required the killer of the dragon to overcome a technical problem, ...
... each solution requires dozens of steps and dozens of wrong steps.
Test missiles were fired but they fell lifeless on the ground or flew in the wrong direction.
Horrible incidents occurred.
But the will now became serious, and the work continued.
But despite the almost unlimited funding and round-the-clock work by technicians, the deadline set by the king was not realized.
The task was difficult.
The contract is concluded and the dragon is still alive, still eating.
But it was getting closer.
A year later, the first missile model was successfully launched.
The completion date of the shell's construction and launch on New Year's Eve was finally determined ...
... Twelve years after the start of the project.
The last days of the year were cold and cloudy, but it was still windy and bright: good launch conditions.
While the sun was gone, technicians were scattering and making recent adjustments.
While the king and his advisers were watching from a platform near the launch pad.
Further away, behind a fence, people gather to watch the great event.
Big clock showed countdown: about ten minutes. The dark dark curved body of the dragon appears behind it as it eats.
From the audience, someone jumped over the fence and ran to the platform where the king was sitting.
He arrived accompanied by security in hysterical condition, and his nose was addicted.
"The last train! Stop the last train!" The man shouted.
The young man was a small employee at the Ministry of Transport.
He discovered that his father was on the last train heading for the mountain.
The King ordered the trains to continue until the last moment, ...
... for fear that would cause a change in the dragon's movement and not hit the rocket.
The young man begged the king to order the return of the last train, ...
... who was scheduled to arrive at the mountain station five minutes before the moment of zero.
"I can not do that," said the king. "I can not risk the dragon's alarm."
The clouds began to rain over their heads.
"I'm very sorry," continued the king. "If we started this project one day before your father had to die."
He said as he looked toward the crowd, thinking of all the losses they were carrying, and he bore them.
"This project should have started years before we started.
Many would not have been killed by the dragon, if only we had awakened from our acceptance of its terrifying existence earlier. "
The young man stopped the wailing.
The king looked up at the countdown hour: five seconds left.
Four.
three.
Two.
One.
zero.
A ball of fire surrounded the launch platform and the rocket went off.
Crowds, king, rich and poor, young and old ...
That white flame that pierces the darkness of the whole human spirit, with its fears and hopes.
And struck the heart of evil.
The shadow bobbed in the horizon and fell.
Thousands of voices of joy rose from the crowds, followed by the sound of the deafening, deafening monster.
After all this time, mankind has finally become free from the dragon.
The cries of joy were noises Cheers:
"Let the king live long!
The royal footnote gathered in the rain gathered around its king.
Much has changed in the last hour
The human right was restored to an open future, primitive fear was extinguished, and many of the long-standing assumptions were reversed.
"What are we going to do now?"
"We've come a long way ...." "But now we are like children again," said the king.
The future is open to us.
We will go and try to do better than we did in the past, because we have time now ...
Time to do things, time to grow, time to learn from our mistakes.
Let all the bells ring in the kingdom until midnight, in the spirit of our dead.
We will then celebrate and begin the process of building a better world. . . Because we have time now.
Translate Alaa